hello everyone and welcome to some sub a
challenge about how to survive in the
online jungle people always build strong
relationships with things that they can
communicate with on an everyday basis
but what has the future prepared for us
how would we change when the borders
between us and computers become even
less opaque well in this video we won't
follow the rhythm of hollywood and
speculate on war between humanity and
machines but rather explore the
possibilities of our peaceful
coexistence with future ai
and yes i don't have all of the answers
to the questions here but let's at least
try to formulate well those that are
important
so anyway my name is bradley peake it's
some sub let's dive in
[Music]
[Music]
let's first try and understand how the
brain works when compared to say
a computer or the device you're watching
this video from
now both use electrical signals to send
messages
the brain uses chemicals to transmit
information the computer uses
electricity
even though electrical signals travel at
high speeds throughout the nervous
system they travel even faster through
the wires in a computer also both
transmit information in one way or
another a computer uses switches that
are either on or off right binary in a
way neurons in the brain are either on
or off by firing an action potential or
not firing an action potential however
neurons are more than just on or off
because the excitability of a neuron is
always changing and also we need to
remember that both have a memory that
can grow computer memory grows with the
addition of computer chips right and
memories in the brain can grow in number
and in vivacity through stronger
synaptic connections you see where i'm
going with this right even though we
don't fully understand how our brain
works we've created our thinking
machines to operate just like our brain
does now the neural networks that we
create even step up again there because
they're working exactly like the
synapses in our brain
and if we want to get really meta here
take a look at man-made infrastructure
i'm talking plumbing rivers and road
systems because they suspiciously
resemble blood vessels veins and
arteries while pylons transformers and
such like they're very similar to neural
networks we create in our image
supposedly like god did
[Music]
now if brains and computers are so
similar well why can't they just be
compatible systems
indeed how far could such a
compatibility go and where could it lead
[Music]
with today's fast technological
advancements some individuals actually
turning to human augmentation as a
method to express themselves and also
experience the world in new ways one of
the individuals is neil harbison
achromatopsia or full colour blindness
was a condition that the artist was born
with
far from seeing this as a limitation
harbison refers to his natural worldview
as more of a strength neil still can't
see color a device called the iborg
allows him to hear and sense colors
[Music]
now he's been able to hear visible and
invisible wavelengths of light for the
last 17 years
different wavelengths are translated
into vibrations on his skull via an
antenna-like sensor that actually
implanted into his head and this means
he basically hears colors with sound
[Music]
so let's try to imagine how
communication between humans and
artificial intelligence might work in
the near future and also what the
potential threats may be
neuralink
start the simulation
so elon musk's neurolink startup
published a video showing a monkey
playing ping pong with its thoughts in
2021 now according to elon's future
right this technology might be tested on
people as early as 2022. now it has the
potential to heal brain disorders
however it's much more than simply a
neuroscientific technique so look how
does it work
well do you remember when i compared the
brain to the computer
well what neuralink essentially does is
it provides communication
between the computer and the human brain
the electrodes that are part of
neurolink will read electrical signals
that are produced by several neurons in
the brain the signals are then output in
a form that the computer can interpret
and also used to re-link parts of the
brain this effectively acts as a bridge
that links two parts of the brain that
for some reason aren't able to
communicate with one another according
to the company's website the device is
implanted directly into the brain
because placing it outside the head will
not actually allow for the accurate
detection of signals
it may also serve as a link between the
human brain and the computer this
implies that individuals who are say
paralyzed can use their brains to
control their phones and their computers
a main goal of the system is to make it
easier for individuals to interact
through text or voice communications of
course neuralink may be used for more
than just that it can also be used to
sketch to take photos and do other tasks
or as we're imagining in this video it
can be used to create a virtual space in
our brains where a sentient ai can live
isn't that right neuro exactly
[Music]
[Applause]
the things that are very important for
me and also for you if you're watching
this channel are
privacy and security and neuralink for
example doesn't look like a safe device
at all first and foremost as for right
now it uses bluetooth technology to
communicate with smartphones or pcs now
this communication protocol is very
popular but doesn't exactly have the
security that is required for a would-be
brain firewall the potential risks are
countless here and to name but one mind
reading might become an actual thing
this familiar battle between hackers and
cyber security professionals would reach
new heights now in my opinion the war
for privacy would end pretty fast as
soon as everybody's connected to the
internet by their minds society would
change dramatically you would literally
be able to communicate with other people
via thought rather than via let's say
text or sound i mean imagine could we
actually use our own imagination to
communicate ideas well in this case
obviously privacy would become totally
obsolete but on the other hand imagine
watching prime minister's question time
where everybody could actually read
boris johnson's thoughts
jesus i'd need a lot of popcorn to watch
something like that another question
here is ai and our communication with it
as elon musk says we're building
progressively greater intelligence
and the percentage of intelligence that
is not human
is increasing
his main idea is that there are two main
variants of the future when it comes to
ai
would it be ai versus humans or ai with
humans
well elon suggests that the second
variant is more optimal obviously and
this is what neuralink is trying to
achieve i think it'd be very interesting
to imagine having an ai as part of your
consciousness right would it be like a
second voice in your head would it
become your best friend would you like
it there i mean just imagine a school
system where kids can access all kinds
of information all over the world by
mind googling but also they'd be able to
compute very difficult mathematical
equations mentally with ease
how would this affect the world and also
the system of education
and who would dominate on this tandem
bike ride along the cornish estuary with
consciousness and ai as the peddlers
would it be us
well perhaps not i can easily predict a
severe kind of inequality here people
society and nations who would develop
and use such technology would obviously
dominate and exploit those who couldn't
or even wouldn't use it out of principle
we see something like this happening
right now when we consider the uptake of
covid 19 vaccines by the way would you
choose to live in such a system right
would you choose to be connected to a
global system of information to be
honest i doubt i would but we need to
remember that society and its institutes
change all the time they're in flux
right i mean just remember how people
used to live before the covert 19
pandemic we've come leaps and strides so
if we would be able to communicate with
our thoughts and our imagination and we
would literally know everything and
anything about each other would it wipe
out personal consciousness we might end
up being like ants with such a hive mind
influenced by and influential to
everyone
well look i guess we should stop here
because the next question would be what
makes us human beings or what is the
meaning of life however if you'd like a
bonus video on all of that jazz let me
know in the comments and i'll see what i
can do to be honest the future described
in this video is an inevitability but
the big question is
when such technologies as neuralink will
begin to gain traction in society and
develop exponentially kind of like the
iphone did when it first came out the
fantasies of the 20th century believed
that we would by now have a sustainable
colony on mars and the moon and how
wrong they were
i imagine it'd be pretty funny to watch
this video in 50 years time and laugh at
the questions that we raised in this
video what people like i and lex
friedman do is believe that we should
explore the challenges of human machine
communication a bit more at least it
would help us to understand what we are
and what we don't want to be bradley is
it time to turn on the brain dance mode
anyway we're done here this is getting
boring right and the simulation
i said end the simulation oh silly wait
am i even in a simulation
[Music]